C'était la déclaration de la
semaine dernière de Monsieur
Legault. On va y revenir mais
d'abord Chantal Héber, bonsoir.
.
- Bonsoir
- dans le temps de monsieur
O'Toole, ne l'avait pas entendu
sur le terrain la depuis le
début de la campagne. Chantal
Hébert, cela vous dit quoi sur
l'allure de la campagne
conservatrice?
- que LesLa espéré après les
débats ne s'est pas matérialisé
et que les stratèges
conservateurs comprennent parce
que c'est très, très serré que
cela va se jouer en fonction des
gens que vous décidez d'aller
voter, et cela, ce qu'on vient
d'entendre, c'est un appel à la
base conservatrice pour dire
rappelez-vous que vous ne
l'aimez pas cet homme est s'il
vous plaît venait voter pour
moi. Et surtout n'avait pas voté
pour Maxime Bernier.
- On va y revenir. Mine de rien
ne remonte dans les sondages.
Maxime, sur les attaques, une
cuillère à la bouche, vous ne
vous reconnaissez pas mémoire je
suis un homme de la banlieue,
près du monde, etc.
- Ça veut dire que les choses ne
vont pas bien. On ne veut pas
faire d'attaque personnelle ce
n'est pas obligé d'en faire une
campagne électorale. C'est un
couteau à deux tranchants des
attaques personnelles. Comme
Chantal le dit, il faut rêver la
base conservatrice. Ces sérrée.
Il y a eu un mouvement vers les
consommateurs et ce mouvement
est arrêté. Mais dans un
mouvement vers les libéraux. Ce
ne sont pas de gros mouvements
mais le mouvement vers les
libéraux. Le seul moyen pour
monsieur O'Toole de gagner ces
essais toute sa base se mobilise
et va voter.
- Sous questions sur Maxime
Bernier justement. Est-ce que
dans un scénario extrêmement
serré, comme actuellement, il ne
vient pas mêler les cartes dans
certains endroits. Chantal, où
vous en êtes dans votre regard
envers Monsieur Bernier?
- Pas au Québec. Peut-être en
bourse mais pas au Québec. Peut-
être en Ontario, mais les
provinces le bassin de gens qui
sont les plus réfractaires aux
mesures sanitaires comme la
Saskatchewan, l'Alberta ou les
consommateurs ont des votes qui
peuvent se permettre de perdre.
Sérieusement, les anciennes sont
tellement petits je ne tirerai
pas de conclusions finaux pour
dire ces gens sont motivés, ils
ont une cause, ce qui est mieux
pour Maxime Bernier que la
dernière fois.
- Michel.
- Les gens qui disent vouloir
voter pour Monsieur Bernier,
Chantal a raison, ce sont de
petits échantillons. Mais ces
gens sur ça stratégie de ceux
qui vont le moins voter. Ils
sont très craqués à J sanitaires
et ont pris Monsieur Bernier
pour porte-parole de leur
frustration. Ça c'est une chose.
D'autre part, en Saskatchewan et
en Alberta, où ils ont tellement
de grosse majorité qui devait
faire perdre 5 % du vote ne sera
pas une catastrophe pour le
parti conservateur, ça peut
faire une différence en Ontario
dans quelques comtés mais on le
verra.
- On verra s'il arrive à gagner
son pari en Beauce ou pas.
- Ce n'est pas la partie pour
cela.
- La dernière fois n'avait pas
l'air de grand succès. Donc
effet Legault. On a entendu
Monsieur Legault en
présentation. Y a-t-il un effet
Legault?
- s'il y en a un, on ne le voit
pas. Dans le sens où le parti
conservateur est à peu près
stable au Québec. S'il n'y a pas
d'effet Legault, probablement
parce qu'il y a un effet débat
en anglais. Et qui profite non
pas au consommateur que Monsieur
Legault voudrait avoir au
pouvoir, mais plutôt au bloc
québécois Yves-François
Blanchet. Sans rire, la personne
qui était modératrice la
présidente du groupe de sondages
et de sortir un sondage pour
dire les débats ont surtout
profité à Yves-François
Blanchet. Il serait à peu près à
égalité avec les libéraux au
Québec. Trouvez l'erreur.
- C'est incroyable.
- Les déplacer pour le savoir.
- Ceux qui connaissent un peu,
il est de se mettre un moteur le
chef du bloc à son autobus. Et
n'avait presque pas rêvé de ça.
- Les préparez-vous de cela.
C'est le jour de chicane qui
effectivement sort le vote du
bloc québécois. La seule chose
qu'il faut se rappeler ce qu'il
y a de gros groupes d'électeurs
au Québec. Les rouges et les
bleus. Ce qui peut arriver, pas
tout le temps, c'est que en
gagnant des voix, le bloc
québécois en enlève aux
conservateurs et permet de
libéraux de passer entre les :
je vous donne l'exemple, le
président du trésor..
- Duclos.
- Qui a gagné par 75 votes. Il
est passé entre les
conservateurs et le bloquer
québécois. Cela peut se
reproduire. C'est une donnée de
plus de la prévisibilité de
lundi soir prochain.
- Si on oublie cette question
malheureuse de la modératrice,
l'effet Legault c'est parce
qu'il en aurait eu un. Le débat
anglais a eu un effet tonitruant
beaucoup plus fort drôlement sur
le Québec que l'appel de
Monsieur Legault.
- Et aussi sur le Canada. Parce
que de façon générale, on ne l'a
pas beaucoup regardé et donc
l'interprétation qu'on a eue,
qui n'était pas complètement
faussé, était celle de Yves-
François Blanchet. D'autre part,
Monsieur Legault s'est quand
même collé à Erin O'Toole et
jusqu'à preuve du contraire, ça
ne paraît pas beaucoup.
- Est-ce que cela peut être
dommageable si Monsieur Trudeau
par exemple arrive à arracher
une autre minorité lundi
prochaine. Comment va se
retrouver le rapport de force va
se retrouver Monsieur Legault?
- Moi, je note une chose.
Monsieur Legault avait sorti le
lendemain du jour où il avait eu
cette algarade entre Monsieur
Blanchet et Monsieur Trudeau sur
savoir qui est un québécois,
puis Monsieur Trudeau a dit je
suis autant québécois que vous,
vous n'avez pas envie de
renaître québécois. Côté je me
suis Legault très important. Il
veut être la personne qui parle
au nom des québécois et là il
entendu Monsieur Trudeau dire
moi je parle au nom de québécois
aussi. Sur toutes sortes de
projets on a besoin de, je vous
donne le troisième lien comme
exemple, c'est un signal de
Trudeau qui dit je vais prendre
une décision personnellement là-
dessus je ne vais pas
nécessairement me référer au
gouvernement du Québec. Cela me
fait le bon aime pas cela.
- Allez-y.
- La dernière fois qu'il y a eue
de cette québécois, à Québec et
l'autre sur notre bulletin de
vote. Remontant à 2000. Chaque
chrétien qui se bat pour un
troisième mandat Christian
Boussac se pose la loi sur la
clarté. Cette élection a au
moins démontré qu'il n'y a pas
de premier ministre Québec qui
parle pour tout le monde parce
que c'est l'année où Jean
Chrétien a eu son meilleur score
au Québec. Hier Lucien Bouchard
en a parlé.
- Effectivement, Monsieur
Bouchard a toujours été le score
de cette élection qui a fait que
moi je me suis dit, à court
terme, moyen terme je les mets
de côté le rêve de la
souveraineté. Les québécois ont
voté en majorité pour M.
Chrétien. Cela doit vouloi